alright this is a fun problem so look at
a video on its own so I started in the
last video but i'm going to start over
just we get it all in one take so they
say the figure above arc SBT arc SBT is
one quarter of a circle with Center are
and radius six centres are and rated 60
they if they actually tell you know they
draw this distance which is the radius
this distance is six right and so that
this distance would also be six right
this distance is also going to be six
it's the radius if the length plus the
width of rectangle ABC r is eight so
this is ABC are so the length plus the
width is eight so let's call this l l
this is w actually this should be well
it doesn't matter let's call them this
should be height this would whatever but
we know that these two sides are equal
to eight so we know that L plus W is
equal to eight fair enough then the
perimeter of the shaded region is the
perimeter of the shaded region that's
this perimeter right here so there's a
lot of pieces to it so let's start with
what i would call is the the low-hanging
the low-hanging fruit so the low-hanging
fruit in my opinion is the length of
this arc from arc SBT all right what's
the length of that well it's going to be
one-fourth of the circumference of the
entire circle right because this Ark
represents one this what we drew is
one-fourth of the circle so this this
length is going to be one-fourth of the
circumference so the length of the
circumference so the circumference of
let me see the circumference of the
circle or it's a calm person is what
it's two pi r two pi r r is six right so
2 pi x 6 2 pi x 6 is equal to 12 pi if
the circumference of the circle is 12 pi
then the though we could call you know
the length of the arc right let's call
this la la the length of the arc is
going to be what it's going to be going
to be one-fourth the circumference of
the whole circle one-fourth times 12 pi
is equal to
three pie this is 3 pi good enough now
what else can we try to figure out well
the second second lowest hanging fruit
is actually the length of this line
which is probably saying well they give
me no information maybe you have to use
the Pythagorean theorem with W now but
it's really just kind of a visual trick
because I'll tell you that you could
actually just look at this graph and
figure out what the length from A to C
is and I'll give you a hint what is the
length from are to be what is that
length well is it are to be a radius of
the circle right it's going from the
center to the edge of the circle so its
radius so RB has length 6 and RB is a
diagonal of this rectangle just like AC
is so they're symmetric so this is also
going to be equals 6 and you could look
at it a bunch of different ways you know
you could say that w squared plus l
squared is equal to this AC squared well
w squared this is w as well right you
could also say that W squared plus l
squared is equal to this side squared so
that's why they're equal to each other
so we know AC we know are we know length
of AC is equal to six as well right so
we figured out that so we have two
pieces left we just have that piece and
that piece what's the length of this
piece well this whole distance is 6 we
figure that out because that's a radius
and this piece is l right that's l so
that piece is 6 minus l and similarly
what's this piece by the same logic
that's 6 minus w right this is w the
whole thing is sick so this left over 6
minus w so if we want if we want d D CIR
come the perimeter of this entire shaded
region it's this perimeter of this brown
arc which is three pie so it's three pie
so let me say perimeter is equal to 3 PI
plus the length of AC plus 6 plus this
piece plus 6 minus L plus this piece
plus 6 minus W and let's simplify that a
bit so let's see what that equals
three pie and then we have three sixes
so plus 18 minus L minus W and this is
the same thing as 3 PI plus 18 minus L
plus W fascinating and really yeah I
kind of just bumbled my way here I mean
you know the problem is solvable and
that's better than most mathematicians
have going for them and so you just kind
of have to bumble away with whatever
information they give you the real trick
here I think is recognizing that AC is
the same length as RB but once you get
to this point you have to now employ the
second trick you have to realize that
minus L minus W well that looks a lot
like this L plus W up here and this is
really kind of what separates the the
adults from the children I guess so we
know that L plus del view is eight so
substitute here eight so the perimeter
is three PI plus 18-8 that equals 3 PI
plus 10 and that is choice B that was
exciting I'll see you in the next
section